- I'm taking a couple of
weeks off and while I'm gone,
some brilliant people are
standing in for me here.
First is Alex from Brainbook,
he's a brain surgeon.
There's nothing gruesome in this video,
but there is the answer to a
question I never knew I had,
how do neurosurgeons find their
way around inside the brain?
- Neurosurgery is fraught with risk.
The brain is packed with
almost 100 billion neurons
compartmentalised into
complex bundles of nerves
and other structures that
make you who you are.
Small parts of your brain
are vital for allowing you
to speak, move, think, learn and love.
As neurosurgeons, we operate in and around
these vital structures and
spend a great deal of time
learning the anatomy so
that we can operate safely.
The room for error can be millimetres
as we manoeuvre around blood
vessels and critical nerves
and damaging any of these can
cause either life changing
or life ending complications.
No matter how good the
surgeon and no matter
how good their knowledge,
we can still go astray
and need a helping hand.
Neurosurgery is a
specialty that's inherently
intertwined with cutting edge technology,
and we can use that to guide us
when we're navigating the brain.
Today I'm going to show
you how neurosurgeons
can use infrared and electromagnetic
image guidance systems
to show us exactly where
we are in the brain
during critical operations
like brain tumour surgery,
or inserting biopsy needles
deep into the brain.
This is a Medtronic StealthStation S8.
It's a combination of
hardware and software
that uses special trackable instruments,
such as this pointer and this stilette.
To be able to guide the neurosurgeon,
the system tracks the
position of these instruments
in relation to the surgical anatomy
and sends that information
to the software.
The software then displays
the instrument's position
on either the CT or MRI
scan of that patient.
The system can track
instruments either optically
using an infrared camera
or electromagnetically.
With optical tracking,
this camera sends out
and then detects infrared light
that's reflected from these silver balls.
The camera then transmits
the instrument's location
to the navigation software.
Similarly, with electromagnetic tracking,
the emitter emits a low
energy magnetic field
with unique characteristics
at every point.
The electromagnetic
instruments contain sensors,
which allow the navigation software
to identify the instrument's location
within the electromagnetic field.
For the software to display
the instrument's location
in relation to images of
the patient, you've got
to help the software by creating a map
between points on the patient
and points in the images.
This process is called registration,
and it's essentially the
same for both optical
and electromagnetic types.
After registration is
complete, whenever the surgeon
touches a point on the patient
using one of these tracked instruments,
the computer uses the map
to identify the corresponding
point on the images.
This identification is called navigation.
And now I'm going to show
you both systems in action.
Here we've got an MRI
scan of a brain model
that we're going to use.
Coming up, you see this
white blob, which is supposed
to be a simulated brain
tumour on the MRI scan.
Up here, you can see an
eye coming into view,
and then the nose.
So this is the brain that's going to
correspond with the model.
In the bottom right hand corner,
we're using infrared tools,
and you can see the pointer
coming into reference
with the reference array
that we've got fixed
to the patient's head.
We're going to be doing
registration as we mentioned before,
marking out lots of points
with the infrared pointer.
Now we can verify the registration.
We've got 1.5 millimetre accuracy,
which will do for this simulation.
So, we're going to touch the
tip of the nose on the model
and you can see in the MRI
that that correlates well.
Let's look at the inner part
of the eye and that looks good.
The outer part of the eye
and the tip of the ear,
and this is all looking like
it's corresponding really nicely.
We put the pointer into
this hole that's pre made,
we're on the tumour, so
that's looking good as well.
And this is a pre made craniotomy
or trapdoor in the skull
that's going to allow us to just
access the tumour straight away.
In real life, we'd make this hole
and that would take about
45 minutes to an hour,
having cut through the skin
and drilled off this bone.
So we can operate around
this tumour and see exactly
where we are in the brain
avoiding critical structures
like blood vessels, nerves
and parts of the brain
that are important for speaking
and seeing, for example.
Now let's move on to the
electromagnetic form of navigation,
which is also called axiom guidance.
We're going to be using a
Rowena neurosurgical simulator
and thanks a lot to
Susie Glover from Delta
and Stephanie Brown from
NHS Healthcare Horizons.
This model is quite cool because it
actually has fluid systems within it
and here you can see
us actually scanning it
and we're going to take these CT images
and plug them into the software.
Here you can see we've
put the model in pins,
but we don't usually do that
because it can interfere
with the electromagnetic system.
We're going to be using
this stilette to guide
a piece of tubing deep into
the brain's fluid reservoirs.
This pointer is what we're going to use
to do a registration.
This is the actual catheter
that we're going to be inserting
deep into the brain and we'll take out
the little metal stilette
that comes with it,
and insert the tracked axiom stilette
that comes with the
electromagnetic system.
So now that catheter is
tracked, we can use this pointer
to mark out exactly what
trajectory we're going to be using
and see where we're going
to need to make a cut
and then later on where we're
going to make a burr hole
which is a small hole in the skull
that allows us to access the brain.
Now we're going to mark it
with a red marker in this case
and start drilling.
[high speed drilling]
Once we've made the hole
and done a bit more work
in real life, we're ready
to put the catheter in.
On the right so you can see
that the StealthStation
is showing us how far we need
to go and shows us a target
that we've pre-planned.
We're going to follow that trajectory
and make sure the green dots line up.
As we advance the catheter down,
it gives us a countdown in millimetres.
Once we reach zero, we should
be in the ventricle system
and as I take out the metal
stilette from inside the tubing,
fluid should start coming out.
And there we are, we are in.
And in real life
we'd now secure this catheter
and get out of there.
- Go and subscribe to Brainbook,
start with his video
on a day in the life of
a neurosurgeon on call.
Next week, we go from brain
surgery to settling on Mars.